MARK MIRCHANDANI: Active
Assist is a collection
of tools and services that
simplify your resource
management experience
on Google Cloud.
In this video, we're
going to show you
three recommenders
that will help
you zero in on the opportunities
to save on the costs
operating in Google Cloud--
the Idle Virtual Machine, or
VM recommender, the VM machine
type recommender, and the
unattended project recommender.
Let's get into it.
On Google Cloud Compute
Engine, you can spin up
virtual machines, and you'll
only be billed for the time
that each is running.
This pay-as-you-go model
is one of the best benefits
of building your
infrastructure in the Cloud.
At the same time,
if your project
has lots of virtual machines,
costs can add up over time.
You'll be paying
for those resources,
whether you're actively
using them or not.
To avoid paying for resources
that you're not using,
there's two things you
want to make sure of.
First, ensure that every machine
that's running in your project
is being put to good use.
And second, make sure that the
virtual machines you're running
have the appropriate
resource allocations,
such as the number
of virtual CPUs,
and the size of the memory.
For example, you'll
probably like
to know whether the VM running
in your development environment
is still being used, or
if it was just a test
machine that
someone accidentally
forgot to turn off or delete.
And if it is being
used, you want
to be confident that it has
just the right resources
configured for the
intended workload.
You could do an audit yourself
to figure these things out,
but if you're looking
at number of projects,
each with multiple virtual
machines, multiple users,
teams, applications,
this can quickly become
a labor-intensive approach.
This is where a
couple of recommenders
can help drastically
simplify the experience
to help avoid paying for
things that you're not using.
First, the Idle VM
recommender will
highlight VMs that
haven't recently
been used so you can shut
them down or delete them
from your project.
The recommendations
for idle VMs are
based on system metrics
that are gathered
by the Cloud monitoring
service over the past 14 days.
For new machines, this starts
a few days after creation.
A VM is classified as idle when
all three of these criteria
are met--
CPU utilization is less than
0.03 for 97% of the VM runtime,
received network traffic is
less than 2,600 bytes per second
for 95% of the VM
runtime, and sent
network traffic is less
than 1,000 bytes per second
for 95% of the VM runtime.
With these criteria met, a
VM is identified as idle.
It's up to you to decide
whether to keep it running,
shut it down, or delete it
completely from your project.
If you shut it down,
it'll stop accruing costs.
Plus, you can always start
it back up if you need it
again in the future.
So that's idle VMs, but
how can Active Assist
help with costs of
machines that aren't idle?
Well, along with the
Idle VM recommender,
you'll also see recommendations
from the VM machine type
recommender.
These recommendations
are also known
as rightsizing recommendations,
because they're all
about finding the right
size for your workloads.
Rightsizing recommendations
are generated
by monitoring the CPU and
memory utilization of running
VMs for the last eight days.
This data helps to identify
if the machines are
not efficiently using all of
their allocated resources.
With that, the
recommender can suggest
a more appropriate machine
type for that virtual machine.
Let's say that you have
an application running
on an n2-standard-16 instance.
That machine type
has 16 virtual CPUs,
and 64 gigabytes of memory.
If your application generally
uses most of the CPU,
but never really uses more
than 16 gigabytes of memory,
you might get a
rightsized recommendation
to use an n2-highcpu-16 instead.
This machine type has the
same number of virtual CPUs,
but has a lot less memory, and
an overall lower hourly price.
When rightsizing
recommendations are
made for machines with
less resource usage
than they have
allocated, applying them
results in a reduction in
costs without impacting
your performance.
The savings will multiply
with every virtual machine
that you're able to downsize
based on these recommendations.
Virtual machines aren't the
only source of costs, though.
Other cost-cutting
recommenders include
the committed used discount
recommender, the idle custom
image recommender, the idle
IP address recommender,
and the idle persistent
disk recommender.
Beyond those resources, the
unattended project recommender
will help you
identify projects that
are potentially unused so they
can be reviewed or deleted.
This is especially
valuable if you're
an administrator for an
entire organization with lots
of projects.
There's a good chance
some of those projects
could have Cloud resources
that are accruing costs,
even though they're not
actively being used.
The way it works is by
analyzing project usage data
over the last 30 days.
For any project with low
usage in that period of time,
and for which there are no OAuth
tokens used in the last 180
days, you'll receive
a recommendation
to review or delete the project.
When you delete
a project, you're
also deleting all of the
resources in that project
that you're being billed for.
This recommender also lets
you take a proactive approach
to managing projects
by identifying projects
that still have usage,
but whose owners are not
active on the project.
For those projects, you'll
get a recommendation
to reclaim the
project by assigning
someone else as the owner.
This can help prevent projects
from becoming unattended
in the first place by making
sure that there's someone
accountable for each of them.
Now, let me show you how simple
it is to discover and apply
some recommendations from
the Recommendation hub
with a few clicks.
In this scenario, I've got the
Compute Recommender Admin IAM
role assigned so that I can view
and manage idle VM and machine
type recommendations.
I also have the
Compute Admin IAM role
so that I'm able to
apply the changes
in those recommendations.
On top of those, I'm also
using the Cloud Spanner Viewer
role to view the CPU utilization
graphs included with the VM
machine type recommendations.
Now that we're in the
Google Cloud Console,
the first place we might
notice recommendations
for our virtual machines is
the Compute Engine VM Instances
page.
This page will show all of the
virtual machines associated
with your project.
There's a summary at
the top of the page,
and individual
recommendations next
to the corresponding instance.
We can see these same
recommendations over
in the Recommendation hub.
Let's start with
the recommendations
from the idle VM recommender.
Here, in the list
of recommendations,
we'll see each recommendation,
the instance it corresponds to,
and the recommended action.
Directly from here, we can
click any recommendation
and perform the
recommended action--
in this case, shutting
down the instance.
If stopping the instance
isn't an option for us,
this machine has
another recommendation--
to switch the machine type.
Let's stop this VM for now.
Let's take a look at the
recommendation from the VM
machine type recommender.
This time we'll see
the recommendation,
the corresponding instance,
the recommended machine type,
and the current machine type.
When we click on one
of the recommendations,
we'll be able to see
a more complete view
of the recommended
configuration.
If we choose, we can adjust
the recommended configuration
and add more memory or cores.
After reviewing
a recommendation,
if we decide it
isn't applicable,
we can simply dismiss
it to have it removed
from the recommendation
hub, and stop
receiving the recommendation.
Otherwise, we can accept
the recommendation
and apply it from here.
Note that this will shut
down the instance briefly,
so make sure there's
redundancy in place,
or that you're working within a
designated maintenance window.
Once the instance restarts
in the new machine type,
the corresponding
recommendation will
be marked as applied in
your recommendation history.
All of the Active
Assist recommendations
we've talked about are designed
to highlight opportunities
to take action on things that
could be difficult to keep
track of otherwise,
especially when you're working
with hundreds, or even
thousands of resources
across many projects.
Idle VM and rightsizing
recommendations
help find resources
that aren't being used,
but that you're
still paying for.
Even better, the unintended
project recommendations
would likely tell you which
projects aren't being used.
And remember, recommendations
are exactly what they
sound like-- recommendations.
We call these features
recommenders, because there's
no one better than
you at knowing
the full details and
best steps to take,
and the recommendations
are only there
to help you identify
opportunities to dig deeper.
You can check out
the documentation
to try these out for
yourself, and don't
forget about the
Recommendation hub, where
you can see all sorts of
helpful recommendations.
Stay tuned for the
next video, where
we'll look at some more
recommendations that
will help you improve
another important factor--
performance.
See you there.